let's do how to deal with
these
social media addicted thotteries
chrome tab
uh
virgin
share so this is another ghosting
segment from virgin i heard it this
morning when i was going in to get my
beard all cleaned up so i could look
like a handsome sexy [ __ ] today for you
guys
and um
it's it's a quick one but this dude
ditched this chick because of her
addiction to her phone and social media
he was a really nice guy about it um you
know your typical canadian
so that's one way that you can handle it
but i want to play it for you guys so
you can hear uh the frame around it and
i'll give you a little bit of advice in
my opinion anyway on how i would handle
something like this uh if i was out with
a chick and she was doing this sort of
nonsense on her phone so
um you guys should
have audio on this if you can't hear
when i'm playing this
let me know let's speed it up because
that'll just take a lot less time
my volume is up and uh again let me know
if you can't hear this uh but you should
be good to go
there's no video feed so i mean you just
need to listen to it really because it's
just these guys in the studio talking
with uh subtitles here we go
it sounds like you are a little bit uh
insecure but don't worry like i get it
this happens a lot tons of guys cannot
handle like my presence on social media
everybody let's welcome
jessica it's ghosted jessica so it's not
great that you're here but we're still
happy to meet you
hi guys hi
oh my god
one of the first things that i want to
state here is that you know what you
will notice is a lot of times when these
women like call into these shows and say
oh i got ghosted by this guy i really
like they don't tell you the whole story
it's like i'm a victim
i don't know why he didn't want to talk
to me
help me out sort of thing right but
i suspect she knew that all of this [ __ ]
was coming it's it's it's a bit of a
a ploy that's played
hey jessica tell us about doug what
happened
oh my gosh doug
okay so
he won't get back to me and like i just
don't know why and this has never
happened to me before and i just you
guys are the experts so i figured maybe
you could help me imagine imagine being
so
like consumed and narcissistic that
you're completely unaware socially
uncalibrated to the extent where
you don't understand that a dude
doesn't want anything to do with you
because you're addicted to posting on
social media i don't know why
you guys are the experts all right let's
hear it
okay all right well let's walk it back
here tell us a little bit about you and
doug and how you guys got started and
where was that when he stopped messaging
you back
okay so we met on hinge like it was like
maybe like three weeks ago and
we were talking a lot through text
and we decided to meet up so last
weekend we went to dinner at king street
west and we had a really great time it
was super fun okay
that's it
well and i don't know if like maybe
something happened like to his phone or
i thought he like followed me and then
he unfollowed me i don't know but he
won't
text me back and i'm just wondering like
what's going on like if he's okay
or like instagram we followed you like
by the way guys um
if you're dealing with the chick that
behaves like this with her phone on
social media
uh don't just ghost her let her know
straight up i don't deal with women that
are addicted to their phones and posting
on social media um let these thoughts
know what's up usually when you're like
i went out to dinner the guy followed me
i'd be like oh that's scary so you're
talking about social media
yeah well yeah i mean like maybe he was
intimidated by me because like i don't
know i was kind of getting some stares
like yeah i mean like i'm you know
whatever i have like i'm popular on
instagram but you know i just
i mean maybe he was intimidated or
scared off i'm popular on instagram like
i was getting stares i'm a god
oh my god the insufferability of this
nonsense
but like i just want him to know like
that i don't care about that you know
what i mean so i just i mean i don't
know a follow unfollow is not a good
move so something doesn't
when you accidentally like something
when you're creeping and it's from like
2016. the trick is you just go through
in like a whole bunch of photos and then
you say sorry about me
no okay you've done that before
okay so here's what we're gonna do
jessica doesn't sound like anything bad
happened that was like you know outward
so what we'll do is is we'll call him
next you listening on the phone and
we'll find out from him uh his side of
the story
okay great oh my gosh thank you so much
no problem
so if you haven't met jessica jessica's
great uh she went on a few dates with
this guy named doug and now we won't get
back to her and she doesn't understand
why now jessica you did sort of mention
that you're at a restaurant with him
last week on king west and you're
getting some stairs can you explain why
that was
well i'm popular on instagram and so i'm
sure people recognize me and i was like
taking some pictures and stuff and i
mean also i looked really good so i
wanted people there okay and there was
some sort of following unfollowing
incident too that you mentioned i'm not
sure there was a doug that followed me
and unfollowed me but i don't even know
if it was him i didn't even like look at
his profile i'm not sure okay
okay so what we're gonna do is call him
with you listening on the phone like we
always do and you know this and i ask
everybody this are you sure you want to
make this call because it can be
harsh
yeah i'm sure okay let's make the call
to doug please
hello hi this is doug
yeah
uh it's adam tj jackson from 99.99 good
morning hi
oh uh
okay all right guys um yeah pleasure to
hear from you i guess
not yet yeah maybe wait on that dog
we're not actually that's gary i just
you know we wanted to talk to you about
an incident last week we understand
um don't ask us how we understand that
you
uh i'm just scrolling through the
comments here i want to see if
somebody's tagged during it this this
popular i'm so popular on instagram note
last week with somebody and
ever since you haven't responded to
their texts and we would classify that
as a ghosting so we're just
investigating
yeah
yeah i
uh
i fear i know who we're talking about
i figured you might because unless you
went to two dinners on wednesday last
week i did not know it's just the one
just the one what's up so what's up with
you and jessica man she's like one of
these these instagram social media
people and um
i am just not that into that sort of
i don't call it narcissism but that sort
of you know uh ego i guess
and that's exactly what it is it's ego
it's narcissism it's
when
women are using their phones they're
pointing the camera at themselves right
they're not pointing at the world
generally taking pictures of things it's
like validate me you know give me
attention and show me your your likes
like
the
the big danger and this was um
this is a lot of data that was put
together by dr leonard sachs who's a
child psychologist and he says you know
the big problem with screens is a lot of
guys
guys you know like young men get
addicted to them
um usually around video games and girls
get addicted to them seeking validation
and approval um from you know social
media uh
it's basically from sims you know at the
end of the day so you can blame sims for
all this
anyway
um and because i wasn't one of her
wild admiring fans or amir for her she
paid zero attention to me yeah okay
can you elaborate on that like what do
you mean
um yeah i guess i can't yes celebrity is
very very into herself and like uh you
know a healthy ego is one thing but um
when it's all about your presence on uh
instagram or tik tok like everything was
an instagram you know what i mean like
everything had to be a photo or a video
that i i should have figured it out
earlier on because she impressed me on
taking her to you guys know eretta oh
yeah yeah that's great just you know i
know now is the the top instagramable
spot in toronto which i thought was just
a nice dinner spot but that was not the
intention okay um
as soon as she got in the car when i
picked her up uh she was on her phone
she did not get off her phone the whole
time so look i mean i just got a message
from shake by the way he said he's his
time zone thing was off so he's so he's
on his way um
the thing about this now if you pick up
a chick and she's on her phone
immediately i would just turn around and
drop her the [ __ ] off
get the [ __ ] out
right
why
why would you even take her out to
dinner to let her spend the night on
your dime taking photographs of food for
her thirsty bettas no we got to the
restaurant i had to take a picture of
her outside the restaurant and we had to
do a tic tac as soon as we got it i'd
take a picture of her outside the
restaurant had to do a tick tock as soon
as we got in are you guys hearing this
[ __ ] from the restaurant
no taking photos of me holding a glass
making me take photos of her holding
that fork over food but i only photos of
me were like of my hands yeah
they got nice hands
well thank you
i'm looking at them right now
[Laughter]
i didn't i wouldn't i didn't really need
a picture of me but like if you're not
even yeah
who are we what are we hiding you know
it just felt i don't know it was weird
man you know fake uncomfortable and um
like i said she just she wasn't present
you know she wasn't there for the age of
the photo is that something that they're
into you know social media cool but like
you said not for you and not really the
time hold on hold on hold on i i think
it's fair that we get the other side of
this is it not sure
okay so you know what doug we did you a
little bit dirty jessica has been on the
phone listen to this the entire time you
got to listen to this [ __ ] now oh hi
doug um hi
oh my god like
are you jealous like it sounds like you
are a little bit uh insecure but don't
worry like i get it
she comes at this dude right now with oh
my god are you jealous it sounds like
you're a little bit insecure
like can you believe the audacity of
this one this happens a lot tons of guys
cannot handle like my presence on social
media but i just want you to know that i
really want to make it work with you
this is the problem with social media
and these young broads today is is is it
like they already have an overly
entitled sense of self-worth
and because they have a following i
don't know what it is a thousand ten
thousand hundred that who cares even if
it's a hundred thousand
thirsty nerds that follow and like her
and slide into her dms on a daily basis
telling her how beautiful she is
she
she thinks that she's important like
this is your job
and i i need a normal guy like you in my
life jessica like
honest yes what do you mean you need him
normal guy another normal yeah like a
normal guy all the guys dated are trash
and doug you're so sweet and nice
um well thanks um i'll tell you it's not
just no the guys i think they can't
handle it that's the lady at the table
next to put the napkin over her head
while you're shining that light on your
food so like
i okay
okay appreciate your i was working like
this is my job
i was working like this is my job you're
freaking kidding me you think that
posting your food on instagram is a job
you dummy
this is
this is it man this is it you know like
a half break
yeah i mean i i get it but like on a
first date like
yeah you say i'm a nice guy you don't
know anything about me you didn't ask me
anything
you know i got very little about it you
were you were in your phone the whole
time i hate to say i don't think you're
far off from the guys you usually date
because like okay okay
it just wasn't great you're not right
for each other okay okay is that is that
fair you guys are not right for each
other that's that's what i'm saying yeah
okay oh my god no like we can jug oh my
god you're so cute
this is like enough with that though i
mean let's where should we go next do
you wanna go to the distillery district
no maybe
like the amount of total
zero self-awareness he's obviously
telling her by ghosting her ass he's not
interested he's he's telling her on the
life call i'm not interested and she's
just like trying to ignore that
completely and be like oh well you know
where should we go next to the the
distillery district let's go to this
restaurant let's go to that
it's like
like zero self-awareness this is like
this is red flag this is a walking
more red flags than a chinese communist
parade with this one all right
well
um okay jessica i um
i don't really know how else to say this
so i'm going to go now um thank you
radio for having me on you're very
welcome
um good luck to you guys and watch what
she does next you find what you're
looking for take care okay
this doesn't make any sense what's
happening what is oh my god you're not
meant to be yeah no i should have hung
up first well no no no no no this
trick's delusional i should have hung up
first what's happening i don't
understand
you should have definitely hung up first
you get him back on the phone so she's
hanging out okay can you do your thing
and take good care okay and congrats on
all your success yeah that's awesome
hard work oh thank you guys all right
have a wonderful day what a bimbo anyway
that's that's life fellas that's life
that's that's what you get with these
thoughts hey guys i really hope that you
enjoyed that short clip if you did
consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unpluggedalpha.com forward
slash shop when you click through you'll
be able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational essentials
for health immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you